doit au mall of very very very véritable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont pas plus déguisés comme hier de
la tête aux pieds ils sont juste là une
perruque pour représenter leur chanteur
et vous allez voir à chaque fois c'est
très très ressemblants
on verra
cela
m
non ce n'est pas vrai
et du monde
avant de sibérie souffle sur la bohème
koné reporté puisque aucun dieu du ciel
ne nous viendrons aide acceptée comme je
suis mal
[Musique]
je reste moi
j'avais qu'une
il a neuf vies
[Musique]
tu vas aller viser la lune l'abattoir
avant
es tu
you are the one formi formi formi
formidable duo are made of very very
véritable tous les instants j'ai tout
sourire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout premier
ap
on
c'est non
chemise c'est sûr
la team 6 mai d'où première fois tout
près
[Musique]